we're all insecure human beings we don't
have enough money we don't have enough
purpose we don't have enough
life and it's because you know we're not
building both our worth and our wealth
at the same time i think so many
advisors are just out there preaching
like save your money save your money
save your money right and and what i've
learned through i'm very technical i've
done comprehensive financial planning
and i'm like you guys all you're doing
is saving your extra money so you can
pay more in taxes or you can give more
to your kids is that really in in
alignment with your values i think we're
so busy living someone else's life
there she is
hi evan i'm so excited to be with you
today i love your platform
amazing well welcome aboard don it's
awesome to connect with you and uh i
love your story i love the whole idea of
fixing your mindset around your money so
uh dawn feels you don't know
is a
she is the money she's the money woman
she'll help you
invest your money keep your money has a
new definition of what it means to be
wealthy and spells it differently than
most people where it's well
w-e-l-l-t-h-y
and
named what the country's first
behavioral financial advisor
why don't we start right there what does
that mean to be the country's first
behavioral financial advisor
well you know sitting with clients for
over 22 plus years one-on-one with
clients helping them build their wealth
and manage their assets i realize there
is still a missing component to how
we're giving financial advice out and
it's really about the behavior and the
relationship people have with money and
i think we're all you know money's super
important we all want more of it i've
never met somebody that doesn't want
more money right evan
but
but it's like why are we chasing the
money and how is it aligned with who we
are and how do we really continue to to
get the right type of advice
to build your wealth but also making
sure to align it with who you are as a
human being and how you're living your
life
it's like you're combining psychology
with personal development with
investment advice altogether
in fact
you said the like the
the word that we've you know defined is
living wealthy w-e-l-l-t is really about
it is really about that personal
development and it's building you know
the technical advice about building
wealth is super important that's why i'm
a certified financial planner and the
psychology and the personal development
around money is super important and i
i define it as living wealthy it's
really about the it's the combination is
we all want security in our life we all
want money security and we all want
personal security and it's really living
life at that intersection and i think we
really have a we have a wealth crisis in
our world right now i think it's it's
all about the foundation of because we
have a worth crisis we're all insecure
human beings we are you know we don't
have enough money we don't have enough
purpose we don't have enough
life and it's because you know we're not
building both our worth and our wealth
at the same time
so what are some of the
mindset issues around money that we have
and how do we fix them
you know i think the the biggest mindset
issue is really
it is a mindset it's all how we think
and i think we're all chasing
what is that enough number and how much
is enough and we don't take the time to
stop and think about
really what that number is and how
what is enough in our life and in taking
that combination of what is the number
and what is enough in life is really
you know what we're all we're all
chasing for i just think you know
evan you and i we sit here and we have
beautiful platforms and we talk to
people all day long and
you know when you peel it back like
people just want to be happy right we
all just want to be content fulfilled
happy but i think we don't really are i
think we're not honest with ourself and
what that is and how you know we haven't
defined really what happyness is for us
and we're just constantly
on this cycle of of chasing i think
we're chasing the wrong thing we don't
take time enough to reset our mind and
to think about life and think about
money so what are some of the
questions that you ask clients or
exercises that you have them go through
because you have a very different
process than most financial planners
yeah you know it's really about using
both the size of your brain you know
some of us are really analytic or some
of us are really creative and i tap into
both sides of my brain so you know
for for 20 plus years for two decades it
was just a technical part and you know
like setting a financial plan and
figuring out what people's goals are and
what their cash reserves are and how to
protect their assets and how to minimize
their taxes and minimize their expenses
and their investments and how they're
going to leave their estate and their
legacy
but you know and i did that
thousands and thousands of times with
one-on-one with clients but but the
really defining moment for me is when
we're like wait a second that's all
important because we need the technical
advice but what about how you're living
like what about creating
more of an alignment with your values of
who you are as a person and where you're
able to own that where you're able to
own your purpose
your vision your core values
your goals and really get crystal clear
on what you value as a human being and
making sure we're building our wealth in
alignment to that area
so can you give an example of uh
of how to do that maybe it's with you
know a current client that we can leave
unnamed or or a theoretical example like
to make it a little more practical for
people
yeah you know i i always go back to this
one particular client where
you know their goal was to retire and to
have
um
and their goal was to retire but they
wanted to move and have a little bit
bigger house
and so we talked about could they afford
that or not
and it really came down to their
you know they told me their values were
were family they're super important for
them to be able to have family their
teenage daughters to come back into the
house during the holidays that kind of
stuff but they all what was really also
important was you know them being able
to travel and being connected with you
know experiencing more of the world but
they only had so much money right they
have x amount of dollars in their
investment portfolio and so what we
really had to take a step back and
really get to the core issue of what do
they really value do they really value a
bigger house
and having their children come back to
you know holiday time and the expense of
that versus the expense of them being
able to really meet their values of
experiencing life and traveling and
spending their money that way because
most of us don't have an unlimited
source of funds
so it's about prioritizing and making
those decisions so it's about getting
crystal clear on what like truly what do
you value like
like pulling that back what is it that
you value as a human being is it family
is it relationships is it spirituality
is it travel is it adventure is it like
alignment like what is truly
the things that you value and then
making sure that we're building our
wealth around that versus just chasing
the dollar so so many of us just chase
we want more we want
nothing like like there's never enough
we just chase chase chase without taking
a step back and going
the why behind the chase like i'm all
about more money
so don't get me wrong like i i'm a
technical wealth advisor and it's about
building wealth but it's about doing it
the right way why don't we use you as a
quick example so what is dawn
value the most and then how have you
altered your investment decisions based
off of that yeah no i think that's a
great question question so
you know i personally value
alignment in life i'm a very spiritual
person i value relationships
i value
success
and um achievement i value excitement
like i have a you can see i have a lot
of energy and what i realized like in my
past i was giving all of those things
really my values and my strengths i was
giving that to clients one-on-one
and i'm about halfway through my career
and i realized oh my gosh you know what
i'm truly not in alignment with the gift
that i've been given and that's really
to influence people and to show people a
different way of thinking about forward
thinking versus backward thinking and
giving people this
opportunity to really value on what's
possible in people's lives i've done
that one-on-one for the last two decades
but i realized i fully wasn't using my
skills and my abilities so that's why i
developed a digital platform so i can
reach more people
and i think that's you know i realized
that my values were
i wasn't in alignment but i wasn't using
them to the full potential does that
make sense yeah no and so then and i
know you got your book coming up uh
about living wealthy and you've got your
courses which youtube will link up in
the description below um
so how does that impact
the investment decisions that you make
so this is i mean i i get that you're
seeing investing as a holistic thing is
how you're spending your time
so that you're creating courses and
you're writing books and you're spending
more time with clients and asking the
questions so they can make a better
decision
how does that if you want to live more
in alignment like if somebody came to
you i'm just trying to use as an example
so people kind of get a sense so
somebody came to say hey you know what
alignment is one of my most important
core values
how do i then build a portfolio
because now we get to the technical side
of the investing how would wha what is
that shift in
what i end up investing in with my money
as opposed to just my time
i don't think it's really in that what
you're investing in
it's how much
money you're going to invest for the
future from a savings perspective and
how much money you're going to have
available to you to be able to spend
today it's about the alignment of the
today and tomorrow it's not whether
you're investing in crypto you're
investing in
international and mid cap and small cap
it's about that that's the easy part we
all have
you know we you have a diversified
portfolio that's 101 of investing but
it's really about how much you're
putting towards your investment for the
future so you can live in alignment with
today and tomorrow i think so many
advisors are just out there preaching
like save your money save your money
save your money right and and what i've
learned through i'm very technical i've
done comprehensive financial planning
i'm like you guys all you're doing is
saving your extra money so you can pay
more in taxes or you can give more to
your kids is that really in in alignment
with your values or do you want to free
up some of that tax money do you want to
free up some of that savings so you can
live for today as well and i think
that's the alignment it's not where
you're investing it's really how much
so if somebody said uh yeah again using
you as an example hey i've i want to
launch a course and i want to write a
book and that's going to cost me money
because i want to invest in this
business then you make the decision to
say okay we'll invest x into your
portfolio that's going to take care of
the future but then also we need to pull
y out so that you can create your
digital course and write your book et
cetera well you're absolutely right and
that to me
like having the digital course and
having a book and i'm doing this
beautiful
high profile event in las vegas in
february we're having celebrities come
and we're having a ton of thought
leaders like that costs a lot of money
to put together right but it's in
alignment with me and so i get to make
the decision on how much i'm going to
spend on that today and how much i'm
going to
save for my tomorrow and so i when i'm
true
to me and i'm living my values and my
purpose and my that's why i call it own
your work like when i'm truly owning my
work
i get true alignment and i'm not just in
this fear-based relationship with money
saying i can't afford to put on this
event and i can't afford to write a book
and i can't afford to build this
platform because i'm all so focused on
my future it's focus on the right
alignment and evan your alignment is
very different than mine like we all
have these beautiful
stories and these these beautiful
alignment opportunities for us and i
think
people need to take a step back and just
figure that out i think
i i don't want to go on on but i think
we're so busy living someone else's life
too i mean people are on social media
all the time and all we're doing is
comparing ourselves and scrolling and
going what does evan have and what i
don't have like in and what what is this
person have why do they have more money
or it seems to like they have more money
we live in this trap of comparison
and i think so much of our extra time in
life is spent on comparing you to me
versus us taking a step back and going
whoa what is it what do i really need
and quit living in fear and chasing the
dollar you got you chase the dollar in a
healthy way and live wealthy
i love that you you you humanize it you
know i think a lot of people are
very afraid to talk to their financial
advisor
put put ask people like uh top 10 who do
you not want to talk to it's like their
dentist their lawyer and their financial
advisor
because they don't understand it
because it's it often gets very
technical and they feel
not good enough and it's like i'd rather
just not see it because then i pretend
like i don't have a problem but you
humanize it and make it feel
not just okay but this is empowering
it's taking something that makes me feel
bad and then turn into something in
power and say hey like we can make this
happen you can you can play in a better
future um and so i love i love the vibe
because
we've had a bunch of financial people
you know on the show come in and talk
and no but nobody leads with this kind
of stuff
right well and you think about it like
money
is probably you know if we really took a
step back like money is probably one of
the most important things in our lives
it's like oxygen like we can't live
without money right and so we all have
this
emotional connection with enoughness
and an emotional connection with money
but what happens is like just like you
said as people start fearing money and
because it's so technical and it's over
their head and they never feel like they
have enough so they avoid it and that's
the last thing we need to be doing we
need to be talking about money
especially women like we don't talk
enough about it's okay to have enough
it's okay to be wealthy it's okay to
have enough money it's okay to want more
it's okay to learn and be educated about
how much is enough
and and celebrate that and empower
people to live a better life and if you
had to peel me back
like
i love money too but if you had to peel
me back it's all because
like my whole whole mission and vision
and goal in life is just to teach better
people a better way to think about
what's possible for them and allowing
them to live a different life and not
get strapped into fear i've been
strapped with fear and anxiety my whole
life
like it's in me genetic lee and it's
just you know it's it's been part of who
i am but once i was able to you know own
myself
and and and understand the psychology
and the technical part about wealth and
understanding how to align my life like
that's when life started getting so much
better for me and now i just want to
share with the world and that's what's
really important because we have this
fearful
thing with money it's just ugly and
gross and i'm like no
let's bring it bring it on and let's
talk about it let's have honest
communication about it and and what we
need to do technically and
psychologically to build more wealth
because we need more money
you talked about women i know that you
know it's on your website in the
materials and some of the courses and
the events and books
obviously there's some things that are
very it's just a human thing but what
what's the difference between men and
women i know it's a broad
brush and not everybody's new like that
but why the focus on women why do you
think it's so needed compared to men not
that you're like turning men away but
specifically women like
why the difference what is the
difference
to be quite frank with you it's really
not just about women i think
i think women are more attracted to this
type of thinking about money
um and i think women
in particularly need this type of
coaching and advice
um
i also think that women
tend to historically not having
um
it's not okay for us to negotiate and to
talk about money and we are very
we're emotional creatures and
men are very emotional it's just that
women actually can it it's more accepted
for us to show our emotions than a man
when a man shows his emotions i'm
generalizing right but when a man shows
his emotions it's it's weak and it's not
as you know powerful and i think that's
why my message probably resonates more
with women and i think my message
resonates more with successful women
because just like myself i've been an
entrepreneur my whole life i'm a ceo of
a multi-million dollar investment
company you know i'm an entrepreneur or
a business owner like my that type of
message resonates with how do you
continue to grow and be at the top of
your game but recognizing that we all
have emotions and and when we don't deal
with our emotions especially as women
and we let the emotions take over we're
not gonna we're not we're gonna limit
our success in it as entrepreneurs does
that make sense yeah i'm curious what
was the
like the evolution of don so you spend
your first home remaining you've been
doing this for a while you look super
young but you've been doing this for a
while
uh
you do it like everybody else says at
the beginning and it's just about the
technical and the numbers and the
question
what what was the thing that sparked the
difference to say
maybe the way everybody else is doing it
isn't enough yeah right
um it's twofold it was me personally
realizing when i had made
five times the amount of income
that i ever thought i would dream of
making
but i still feared that credit card
statement back in the day when we used
to get those credit card statements we'd
open it up like oh my god what the hell
did i spend over the last month like i
would still
have this fearful relationship with
money myself
and i would allow that to continue to
dictate my decision making
and i noticed it myself
and then i noticed it like i would give
all my clients
the i'm a cfp i'd give them the right
financial planning advice
but then we'd have meeting after meeting
after meeting and i realized oh my god
like you guys still think you're gonna
run out of money like what is your
problem like i'm showing you the
technical financial plan i'm showing you
a thousand different scenarios that's
gonna show you to never run out of money
why are you guys not spending your money
like you know so i realized oh my gosh
there's this ying and yang with spending
and this emotions and and retirees are
still not spending their money and
they're all they're doing is hoarding it
and saving it or or we have people that
are overspending you know like like i
got myself caught up in overspending
earlier on in my career it's like
because i wasn't enough so i spent
enough to be enough you know and i
realized
this ying and yang
relationship with spending and saving
was impacting me as the leader of a
wealthy you know with leading clients
and i realized the clients weren't
listening to my technical advice i was
like go dang it well i need a different
approach like i need people to fall in
love with their money and realize that
they can like loosen up the purse
strings a little bit and live we all
just want to live and and and they
weren't able to do that until i started
having those conversations with them but
i'm telling you i didn't recognize that
in the clients
until i started recognizing it myself i
was like oh
mama here needs to work on her you know
like i need to work on my own
relationship with money i had all the
technical advice i had all the income
coming in it wasn't until it's like oh
yeah so we need to combine
this relationship the psychological the
the personal development piece of money
and the technical advice at the same
time and i feel like if advisors aren't
there
advisors out there if they're not
helping their clients with both of that
those things
like we're doing a disservice to clients
i've watched clients fall asleep in
meetings when i start pulling up the
morningstar report and talking about the
beta and the alpha and you know like all
the like the technical stuff about
building wealth they're like what like i
i saw them you know how you've seen
people like pretend to yawn
or not pretend again but they're yawning
but they're trying to hold it back
yeah
yeah it's like oh my why are we why am i
wasting i'm wasting their time and i'm
wasting my time so let's get to the real
issue of how they want to live like and
that's where i was just like you know
what i need to make a change and how i
present advice how i give advice the
technical stuff's super important but
you just need to make that change
were there any rules that helped you
then and maybe even now that
maybe gave you the permission whether
it's i'm going to spend x percent of
what i make right i'm going to donate x
percent of what i make like were there
any like okay i have no choice to set
these rules
did anything like that help you get over
the the mindset huh
ah 100 and this is the technical advice
and so you know all through financial
planning when we sit down with clients
we don't really care about their budget
or their spending we're just like how
much you have and how much are you
saving for your future and i was like
this is not okay so what i developed is
a comprehensive financial planning tool
that said okay you guys
we need to understand
this alignment piece and what your real
net income is we all think of when we
hear the word net income we think well
net income is after we've saved or after
we've paid our taxes
it's like yeah but that's not really
what
real net income is after you paid your
taxes and after you've committed a
percentage of your gross income to
saving for your future because we have
to save
and then we have this real net income
after taxes and after saving then we get
this pile of money
that we get to align into different
buckets we get a saving or we get a
spending bucket we get a debt bucket we
get a core value bucket and we get a
charitable bucket like how much money
are we we're giving away so i have these
four buckets that i say okay people
based on your core values like evan if i
picked on you right now and said
name your five core values and then what
i would do is i would say okay i'm gonna
start to
analyze those values and
understand if they're costing you money
from a you know spending perspective or
are they helping you save money and
those core values if there's if if you
are living out those core values and
they're costing you money great then you
can spend 25
of your real net income on the things
that you value the most in life like how
cool is that is it going out to dinner
is it working out is it building your
business like what are your what are the
things 25
guilt-free
guilt-free non-negotiable every single
month 25 of your real net income on the
things you love
and you can spend 35 percent of your
real net income on debt like i love debt
too like i love healthy debt i don't
like credit card debt okay i hate credit
card debt but healthy debt to build
yourself up for the future and and debt
that it's associated with an appreciate
appreciating asset like like 35 of your
money of your real net income on debt
and then 35 percent of your money and
all of the bs stuff that we have to
spend our household expenses on right
just to survive
and then you know a portion you can you
know five percent of your real net
income on charitable giving like when
you follow that bucket you create a
spending plan not a budget you create
you create freedom and security for
today while you're still planning for
tomorrow and that is the technical
advice that i give clients to be able to
live in alignment with their today and
their tomorrow
yeah one of the hardest things i had
to deal with was just getting
comfortable spending money i'm still
like at the core
the startup entrepreneur making 300 a
month like eating bean salad lunch every
day and just having no money uh and so
even when i had money
i i didn't i didn't spend it and
i thought that was actually good but
then realized oh but like
you could you could be doing more things
to bring enjoy in your life but also
invest into the business like i wasn't
growing my company as much as i should
have because i was too afraid to spend
money on things um
so i'm a lot better but i probably still
have a lot of that
scarcity early evan in there too that
i'm still working through well and i
appreciate you saying that evan but you
know your platform is about your belief
walks that you take
right and your beautiful brainy walk
yesterday with your wife and then the
disney right like i i saw it um but the
belief walks because i believe when you
start peeling back the personal
development and building your work up
i'm telling you it a hundred percent
comes down to what you believe in and do
you believe in yourself enough and your
energy of action you're going to take
around building your business
then if you do
then you're going to put more of your
money and your financial resources in
fact you can even take out debt to do
that if you're going to believe in
yourself a hundred percent and you're
going to follow through on your actions
and that's a great that's a great
alignment piece right if you don't 100
believe
and you still live in this fearful
relationship and you let your negative
anxiety and emotions take over your life
and you don't 100 believe you know then
you're going to fail or you're going to
you're not going to be as successful as
you want to be
so it is about beliefs and i love that
that's why i love your platform so much
because when i start peeling back worth
and wealth
the floor the bottom line denominator is
belief it's all how you believe in
yourself and your wealth
um but you but you probably still also
what you just said too it's like you're
spent you need to loosen up some of the
pers you need to like you need to live
for today and you need to have a
spending plan because like like it's
like telling i told another podcast i
did a couple weeks ago it's like you
know if you don't do that you don't
loosen up and live today it's like being
on a diet your whole life like and we
all know that never like 100 of the time
that never works
a hundred percent of the time being on a
budget doesn't work either it's the same
concept
right and we want to live life on
actionable steps that we can take that
work not what is going to limit how we
think and what we believe in and that
also limits our wealth building
opportunities
i love it well you're you're bringing up
all sorts of uh
anxiety and feels here so i've got some
work to do i gotta i gotta get the book
i gotta join the courses what what where
do you wanna send people to you've got
your your event coming up you've got
books you've got courses what's the main
thing you wanna guide people to my
biggest thing oven is i want people no
matter where they're at in their journey
of wealth building
that they can reach out to me for advice
and help if they want free advice they
can follow me all over social media if
they want they're like oh i'm ready to
implement some of this actionable advice
they can go to my website dawndalby.com
i mean there's something for everybody
there the book living wealth or live
wealthy is going to be
all over the place in april of next year
it's going to be online it's going to be
in the brick and mortar stores
i'm super pumped about this event so if
you're a female and you really want to
make a big impact in your life and you
want to learn how to build both your
wealth and your worth at the same time
we have owned your worth experience just
go to my website you can learn all about
everything there and i'm so happy to
connect with anybody because i'm telling
you
it's your mindset it's your thinking
it's your ability to make better
decisions about yourself and you're just
one decision away from living a wealthy
life
i love it well youtube will link to all
that in the description below go check
it out don thank you for your time the
energy the gift uh helping me but the
audience and the big mission you're on
super inspiring and can't wait to see
all the amazing things that you create
thank you and thank you for having me
like i said i i
i'm so impressed with you and your
platform it's been a pleasure
much love thank you don all right thank
you to see my sit down with tony robbins
personal financial advisor check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there there's this myth the
market goes up the market goes down
that's not really true so how do i know
who the person is to help me build my
wealth plans like how do i identify that
person